en vídeos previos vimos que podíamos
describir una curva en base a la función
de valores vectoriales de la posición la
cual en términos generales será la
posición x como función de tiempo por el
vector horizontal unitario más la
posición y en función del tiempo por el
vector vertical unitario y está
esencialmente describe si te imaginas
que es una partícula y el parámetro t el
tiempo entonces describe la posición de
esa partícula para un tiempo t dado así
que si queremos establecer para una
curva en particular digamos la curva c
escribiríamos su función r de t la cual
será aplicable para valores de t entre a
y b y esto va a escribir una curva en
dos dimensiones declamación una gráfica
aquí aquí pagamos una gráfica
repasaremos lo que hemos hecho en los
últimos vídeos la curva podría ser algo
así donde aquí estaría te iguala aquí te
iguala ve y entonces aquí tendríamos el
vector
y a medida que va creciendo el tiempo si
esta es una partícula no necesariamente
una partícula pero bueno si esto es una
partícula es fácil de imaginar a medida
que va creciendo el tiempo los vectores
se van moviendo sobre la posición de la
curva eso lo vimos dos vídeos atrás y en
el último vídeo vimos qué es lo que
significa tomar la derivada de una
función de valores vectoriales y se nos
ocurrió la siguiente idea que de hecho
no fue una idea es más bien la
definición dijimos que r prima de t la
derivada de una función de valores
vectoriales también es a su vez una
función de valores vectoriales y va a
ser igual de acuerdo a como lo definimos
a x prima de t por i + d prima de t por
jota lo cual también lo podemos escribir
como la derivada de r con respecto a t
que es igual a la derivada de x con
respecto a t es la derivada estándar es
una función escalar así es que esta es
la derivada de estándar de x en de t
y más del pj por j
ahora si queremos calcular el
diferencial hay toda un desarrollo
matemático complicado alrededor de esto
no voy a ser muy riguroso aquí
simplemente vamos a imaginar que esta
expresión la puedes multiplicar por un
pequeño dt o de hecho por dt y así
obtendríamos el valor de the air' que va
a ser igual de equis en de t por d te lo
puedes cancelar lo va a escribir aquí
por i
más del dt
por dt
por j
y esto lo puedes escribir voy a poner
las maneras en la cual se puede
reescribir esto como de erc que es igual
x prima de t
dt
por y perdón x prima de t
y x prima desde x en dt por dt por y más
y el prima dt que es de jane dt por dt
por jota y ahora para completar la
trifecta podemos escribir esto como una
tercera opción que sería de r es igual a
y aquí podemos cancelar de test para
tener de x por i + d i
j y esto ese sentido con lo que podemos
intuir porque si aquí tenemos este
vector
y este vector y la diferencia entre
ellos sería este pequeño valor
correspondiente a tr y está compuesto
por el cambio en x que es nuestra de x
este pequeño cambio aquí lo puedes
imaginar aquí en el punto de x x y
estamos vector izando lo al
multiplicarlo por el vector unitario en
la dirección horizontal más de jeff por
el vector unitario en la dirección
vertical así que cuando multiplicas este
cambio por el vector unitario obtienes
este vector aquí este vector aquí y
cuando multiplicas este cambio por el
vector unitario de hecho es negativo
obtienes este vector aquí de tal manera
que cuando suman las dos tienes el
cambio en el vector de posición esto que
te presentado es como un antecedente que
nos va a ser útil para futuros vídeos de
hecho aquí lo voy a dejar porque lo que
quería hacer con este vídeo es que te
familiarices con esta anotación en el
siguiente vídeo lo que voy a hacer es
darte el sentido intuitivo de lo que
significa exactamente de lo que
significa exactamente este término de
aquí y reprima dt y cómo cambia depende
de las distintas parametrización es lo
voy a hacer con dos parametrización es
para la misma curva